President Putin thank you for speaking
with us I am gonna get to some specifics
about the summit in a moment but let's
begin with the big picture President
Trump said in his news conference that
our relationship has never been worse
but that changed a few hours ago how has
the relationship big picture between the
US and Russia changed today no it was
not a pollution issue a number doesn't
primarily I think we should be grateful
to our staff and our aides who spent
several last months working with one
another and not just in the preparations
of this Senate I'm referring to the
effort of our agencies across the board
who working even the very sensitive
areas sensitive both for Russia and the
United States primarily I refer to the
counterterrorism efforts today with
talking with President Trump we agreed
that terrorism is a greater threat than
it seems at first because god forbid if
something happens the reserve there is
attack using the weapons of mass
destruction if they gather hands to
weapons of mass destruction it may have
a devastating ramifications and so our
military our special agencies do
establish cooperation and this
particularly important area a case in
point would be our cooperation in Syria
although there are some understanding
missing to some extent especially in
terms of a broader picture but this
cooperation is going on between the
military between the special services
that is our counterterrorism effort in
the general sense of the word
Madden in 2021 the New START treaty is
about to expire so what we're going to
do next
I reassured President Trump that Russia
stands ready to extend this treaty to
prolong it but we have to agree on the
specifics at first because we have some
questions to our American partners we
think that they are not fully compliant
with the treaty but this is for experts
to decide we also discuss the Iranian
nuclear program we discussed what we can
do to improve the situation with the
North Korea I've pointed out and I will
point out again but I think that
President Trump contributed a lot and he
did a lot to settle this issue but in
order to achieve complete
denuclearization of the peninsula it
would take international guarantees and
Russia stands ready to make its
contribution to the extent that will be
necessary so we can say several issues
of crucial importance for us this and
some others we are starting to achieve
some understanding which gives us
sufficient ground to say that some
things a lot of things change to the
better during today's meeting but do you
see the summit as a turning point and
end by effort of the effort by the West
in recent years to isolate Russia we
just do it usually I think you see for
yourself that this efforts failed and
they were never bound to succeed I mean
take a look at the scale and the sheer
size of it the importance of it in terms
of international security and the
economy
take the its contribution into the
global energy market
it's too big to to be sanctioned and
isolated speaking of the things that do
unite us though and the things that
require our joint efforts it brings us
to the idea that such attempt to fight
one another should be ended and
rather look for ways to address common
differences to address common issues and
challenges how to overcome this how to
address this common concerns so I think
this is the beginning of the path this
is a start we did make a good start
today mr. president one of the issues
that is standing in the way of more
progress as you know are the allegations
of Russian interference in the u.s.
election you have repeatedly said and
you said again today that this was not
the action of the Russian state that if
it was anything it was patriotic Russian
individuals I have here the indictment
that was presented on Friday from the
Special Counsel robert muller that says
that 12 members of russian military
intelligence that GRU and they talked
specifically about units 26 165 and
seventy-four 455 they say you smile let
me finish they say that these units were
specifically involved in hacking into
democratic party computers stealing
information and spreading it to the
world
to try to disrupt the American election
may I give this to you to look at sir
here no prints no [ __ ] possible to me oh
well let me start answering your
question with something a little bit
different let's have a look at it this
way people are talking about the
perverted interference of Russia with
the election process in the United
States I've mentioned this and 2016 and
I want to say it now again
and I really wish for your American
listeners to listen to what I say first
of all Russia as a state has never
interfered with the internal affairs of
the United States let alone in
selections this is the indictment it
shows I have 12 names here it talks
about specific units of the GRU Russian
military intelligence is the GRU not
part of the Russians day yes you're my
teacher I'll get to it just have some
little a little bit of patience and
you'll get a full answer to your
question interference with domestic
affairs of the United States do you
really believe that someone I can from
the Russian territory could have
influenced the United States and
influenced the choice of millions of
American whether they tried yes just a
picture I'm about to answer it's just a
fish okay well this was the first point
that I'm trying to make if you have some
patience you'll hear the entire response
okay Richard I said this in 2016 and I
said now the idea was about hacking an
email account of a Democratic candidate
was it some rigging of facts was it some
forgery effects that's the important
thing that I'm trying to important point
that I'm trying to make was this any
false information planted yeah no it
wasn't these hackers that I've been
discussed and I'll get back to it just
bear with me for a moment
as we're getting told they hacked a
certain email account and there was an
information about manipulations
conducted within the Democratic Party to
Incline the process in favor of a one
candidate and as far as I know the
entire party leadership
resigned they admitted the fact of their
manipulations so that's one thing that
manipulations when the public opinion
should stop and an apology should be
made to the public at large as well
instead of looking for the responsible
the party at fault and mention things as
I said in the press conference may I
just say yours that you're indicating
that they stole real money chilling I
answer that money so are you saying it's
okay because of the facts that they took
from the DNC from John Podesta it was
their real emails so it's okay to hack
and for spread this information out and
interfere with the election Dominion
listen to me please the information that
I am aware of
there's nothing false about it every
single grain of it is true and the
Democratic leadership admitted it the
first time now the second point if you
don't like my answer you can give it to
me a straight away and I just keep
silence and if you want Americans to
listen to my opinion could you please
wait for a little bit and now for the
specific accusations first of all
special counsel Miller has accused a
certain private company in Russia that
is not even a very big enterprise since
core area of competence is a restaurant
business and now this company hired
American lawyers and defending its
integrity and reputation in an American
Court so far American Court has not
discovered any trace interference
whatsoever do you know it or not but let
the millions of Americans know about it
and now up to you the individuals from
the indictment act we were the United
States we have a
for assistance in criminal cases an
existing treaty that exists from 1999
it's still in force and it's works
efficiently today I referred an example
of its efficient work and I'm not just
let me finish
tre you're trying to drive but I will
finish
why would Special Counsel Mueller send
us an official request within the
framework of this agreement our
investigators will be acting in
accordance with this treaty they will
question each individual that the
American partners are suspecting of
something why not a single request was
filed nobody sent us a single move on to
other subjects why do you think Robert
Muller issued this indictment three days
before you and president Trump Nepgear
at the summit absolutely it is I'm not
interested in this issue this single bit
it's the internal political games of the
United States don't make the
relationship between Russia and the
United States I don't hold it hostage of
this internal political and it's quite
clear to me that this is used in the
internal political struggle and it's
nothing to be proud of for democracy to
use such dirty methods and the political
rivalry do you think they were do you
think that mr. Muller is trying to
sabotage the relationship yet in the key
word Abuja I don't want to make any
assessments about his operation it is
for Congress that appointed him to do
this to assess his performance and I
think Court actually had some doubts
about the do procedure about appointing
special counsel Miller to the post that
he now health
I think that American Court now believes
that it was done with the infringement
of the American legislation but that's
none of my business please address it
yourself like the department within this
treaty use this procedure to address us
I thought the news conference today my
opinion was a bit curious because
President Trump spent more time
criticizing the Democrats and asking
about the Democratic server than he did
in criticizing Russia and asking about
the GRU there are many theories in the
United States about why President Trump
is so reluctant to criticize you and I'd
like to ask you about a couple of them
one is that you have something on it
compromise the other is that is a
skilled politician and a former KGB
officer you know how to play him you use
phrases like fake news and deep state
and my question is do you find President
Trump
easy to deal with Lucas it's took I said
well the first point I'm about to make
is why did we take talk about like dope
polite people
why should this come as a surprise was
it worth going all the way to Helsinki
going through the Atlantic to just
insult one another and it's not exactly
the diplomatic standard in the world
there's no need to go and meet
personally if you just want to insult
another person we met to try to find a
way for improving our relationship and
not aggravating it or destroying it
completely and the second part of the
answer is whether we have something on
them we don't have anything on them and
there can be anything on them I don't
want to insult President Trump when I
say this and I may
come as rude but before he announced
that he will run for presidency he was
of no interest for us he was a rich
person but while there is plenty of rich
persons in the United States he was in
the construction business he organized
the beauty pageants but no it would
never occur to anyone that he would
think of running for president he never
mentioned his political ambitions it
sounds like is another nonsense I just
mentioned this in the press conference
st. Petersburg economic forum was
visited by 500 businessman pretty much
every one of them is a major industrial
estate tycoon of greater scale than
President Trump do you think that our
special services actually organized
surveillance on each and every of them
well unlike you and like the United
States we don't do this we don't have
the enough resources we don't have
enough manpower to organize the total
state of control that's not part of our
plans and it's clear that we did nothing
of that kind against mr. Trump I'd like
to ask you a couple of specific
questions about NATO if NATO were to
move to add either Ukraine or Georgia to
the Alliance how will you respond be
threatened No well negative situation
around NATO is going along those lines
I'm pretty clear I have a pretty clear
understanding of how the decisions are
made I know the about the consensus rule
but before the consensus based decisions
are made with on the organization-wide
basis there is an opportunity for
bilateral contacts with the member
states which was done in people with
Poland with Romania which now stationed
and deploy elements of the strategic and
the missile defense of the United States
for us was a direct and immediate threat
for our national security so accordingly
moving this NATO infrastructure towards
our borders would be a threat
and the reaction would be extremely
negative secondly there are two major
NATO exercises later this year anaconda
and Trident juncture did you and
president Trump discussed those and did
he give any indication as he did with
Chairman Kim of North Korea when he
agreed to stop participating in war
games did he give any indication that
the u.s. might not participate in these
two NATO operations you know we haven't
brought this issue up although it is a
concern for us since the NATO is
expanding its infrastructure and
facilities number serviceman is on the
rise and the regions where they
shouldn't be they increase this men
power to the tune of 10,000 people this
is in compliant to the treaties between
Russia and NATO and this is
destabilizing factor which we have to
factor in but we haven't mentioned this
today with President Trump I want to ask
you about Russia's involvement in Syria
according to independent monitors since
the Civil War began in 2011 more than a
half a million people have been killed
and Russia has bombed civilians in
Aleppo and gouda no qualms about killing
innocents
wasn't it to cook the idiot Rana you
know when there is a warfare going on
and this is the worst thing that can
happen for the humankind victims are
inevitable and they always be a question
who's to blame I think it is the
terrorist groups who are to blame who
dis stabilize this situation in the
country the ISIS the jihad al-nusrah and
the like those are the true culprits at
the chariot Americans cave and that's
exactly the answer that American
military gave us when they hit military
or civilian objects in Afghanistan or
other countries
and it might seem dubious to some people
but in fact it is true in terms of Syria
American aviation bombed city of Raqqa
bombed quite heavily and today we
discussed the need for humanitarian
operation to be put in place and I hope
we'll make progress in this area we
would really like for the plans that we
discussed today to be carried into life
but the UN Commission that is
investigating Syria says and I quote
their words there was deliberate
targeting of civilians by Russian pilots
flying su-24 and 34 military aircraft
you should come and say well all of it
can be verified and assessed but I just
want to get back to Rekha very clearly
okay well we can discuss both but should
we also throw in Raqqa for a good
measure we shouldn't take things out of
the context and completely forget about
others shall we I don't think that there
has been the bloodshed in Raqqa that
there was the hundreds of thousands of
people who were killed in Aleppo and in
gouta and in the entire Civil War half a
million people by some estimates 20,000
children have been killed by the Assad
regime and his supporters in Moscow are
they terrorists there it is a neutral
judge to win his naked you are
completely deceived and I'm very sorry
that you do not know the real situation
in about Syria a huge proportion of
civilian population of Raqqa died it was
erased from the face of the earth it
reminds Stalingrad from the world war
two and there's nothing good about it
and I reiterate the blame is on those
individuals who who take guidance from
the terrorists believe
use the civilian population as as
hostages at the g7 summit President
Trump reportedly told the other leaders
that Crimea might as well be Russian
because everybody there
speaks Russian did he give you any
indication that at some point not today
but at some point he might recognize
Russia's annexation of Crimea were lift
sanctions were move to bring Russia back
into the g7 now the g8 all of which
happened as a result of the annexation
of Crimea was operated first of all I'd
like to make a correction the joining of
Crimea to Russia is not an annexation
well the in democratic governance free
free manifestation of a person's will is
a referendum and people in Crimea went
to a referendum and voted for joining
Russia well if this is annexation what
is democracy then secondly we are aware
of president Ramesses I was sure that
the Crimea is part of Ukraine he told me
today I responded with the words pretty
much similar to what I said to you and I
think we should leave a discussion at
that all right we're running out of time
anyway let's let's move on last year
defense secretary mattis said that
Russia is the greatest threat Russia is
the greatest threat to the United States
and he has since made it clear an even
greater threat than terrorism in March
you introduced a new generation of
Russian missiles including what you
called an invincible missile you said
that could evade defeat all of our
missile defenses and you even released a
video that showed the super missile
flying over the United States and
hitting Florida very near
we're president Trump's estate is at
mar-a-lago aren't you escalating the
arms race and aren't you being
deliberately provocative state CDU
material as far as the footage is
concerned they do not specify that the
the missile is about to hit the United
States you have to look at it more
carefully secondly there was not signed
Florida there was not a caption saying
Florida they could take a more careful
look of it it's never a caption no but
you can see it here that it was flying
over the eastern coast of the no no it
couldn't be seen on the map just take a
closer look and don't try just carry a
population with the many belief friends
I can give you as a present this footage
and now the offensive weapons they were
not born out of nowhere they were born
as a response to do unilateral
withdrawal of the United States from the
ABM Treaty from the very beginning we've
been warning our American counterparts
that I'm going to join this global
anti-missile system we see no purpose
for it but we'll do everything to make
means to overcome it well the response
of our counterparts was that the United
States design this anti-missile defense
system because it's not against it's not
designed to be guided against you in
2003 or 2004 I think I imagined
mentioned one of those systems and there
was no response from our American
counterparts so what we did now we just
demonstrated that we do have means to
overcome the system it's just a
negotiating item I do hope that in terms
of strategic stability we'll be able to
find me
an acceptable solution for both sites
and that applies to the INF treaty and
the intermediate and shorter range
missiles as well I have limited time I'd
like to ask you about the alleged INF
violation but I want to move on and ask
you three final questions about Vladimir
Putin when you were first elected in the
year 2000 you were portrayed as a
democratic reformer you talked about the
value of European culture and you did
not even rule out becoming a part of
NATO what happened what someone you
should opinion no it needs me no well
nothing changed about me I am the way I
am I own the way I was I was elected as
the president of the russian federation
as an adult man and in this age your
preferences beliefs and attitude towards
life does not change that much but we
have to react to what's going on around
us well take the NATO expansion to to
the east when the Soviet Union was
withdrawing troops from Germany Russians
should know we were told that Russians
should know one thing that NATO would
never extend beyond the German borders
within two ways it happened
despite our principal posture nobody
gives a damn about our posture
well we didn't United one the United
States to withdraw from the ABM Treaty
but they did despite our requests not to
do it all the requests were denied and
the examples abound take events in
Yugoslavia and Yugoslavia
you need you know that President Yeltsin
was
completely against the this conflict and
the only legal way to use the force is
through the sanction of the Security
Council of the United Nations and
examples abound that examples of events
that deteriorated the status of our
relationship or take the application of
us legislation extraterritorially beyond
its borders it would not us who made
these steps you asked me about Crimea
you'll ask me about Ukraine if we're not
us who organized the military coup and
the country that completely ignored the
Constitution not us who was given pies
on the city squares it is not the way to
deal with such such issues and when it
happened it happened exactly by our
border so nothing happened to me what
happened to you is what I want to know
what happened to the West you say
nothing happened to you but I need to
ask you domestically not internationally
domestically inside Russia why is it
that so many of the people that oppose
Vladimir Putin end up dead were close to
it
former Russian spy and double agent
Sergei scruple the victim of a nerve
agent attack in England Boris Nemtsov a
political opponent gunned down near the
Kremlin investigative reporter Anna
Politkovskaya murdered in an apartment
building why is it that so many people
who were political enemies of Vladimir
Putin are attacked a proponent of
politics keeper chemical first of all
all of us have plenty of political
rivals I'm pretty sure president Trump
has plenty of political right don't end
up known if you do I wash the president
of noon do not always well haven't
president's been killed in the United
States have you forgotten about it has
Kennedy been killed in Russia in the
United States stop [ __ ]
place we did Oh mr. king what and
what happens at the clashes between
police and civil society and some
several ethnic groups well that's that's
something that happens on the US soil
all of us have our own set of domestic
problems but going back to what happened
in Russia yes we do have crime and we
unfortunately there are some crimes and
some extent Russia's statehood is
maturing and there are some side effects
and we persecute people responsible for
these crimes but since you've mentioned
this creep pal case we would like to get
at least some sort of a document and
evidence about it but nobody gives it to
us it's the same thing as the
accusations with meddling in the
election process in America we've
recently heard that two more people
suffered from the same nerve agent that
is called Navi choke but I have never
even heard the last names of this
persons who are they what supposedly
they picked up the bottle that was use
that without scruple I can may I ask you
one last question sir well no let us
seal this issue first what kind of
package what kind of bottle what's the
chemical formula who who got it or maybe
there are other reasons reasons of death
well maybe it's the internal reasons
within the United Kingdom but nobody
wants to look into the issue now we just
see the ungrounded accusations what why
is it done this way why our
relationships should be made worse by
this pretense we have to build them with
the UK as well finally I know one of the
reasons that you wanted to do this
interview was so that people in the
United States and the West could get a
better understanding of the real man you
are often portrayed as a strong man an
autocrat a person who is a symbol of
Russia's strength are those fairer
characterizations of you sir you can do
stupid
Hulan receive I'm not laying claim to be
this kind of a strong man that I am
being portrayed but from the point of
view of legal symbols flag the him all
of them symbolize the country and it's
the same for any country the anthem the
the the the national flag Institute of
the presidency they portray Russian
values and what it ready to go for what
it ready to stand for in order to build
a relationship with such a great country
as the United States I've mentioned the
economy before and I mentioned this
facts to President Trump let's look at
our market for instance Europeans sell
hundreds of billions of dollars worth
and about fifteen hundred billion euro
of services the number for China stands
at fifty seven billion dollars and what
about the United States twelve twelve
billion dollars for the United States
and five billion dollar word for
services so that's the direct result of
this policy including the sanctions in
fact the United States have driven off
their companies from the Russian market
so they left and they this vacuum was
filled by their rivals but their
competitors some of them lost their
investments what was that for we are
interested in developing our
relationship in the area of security of
strategic stability economic challenges
strategic challenges and any other
challenges that we have I think that
today with President Trump we've made
the first step in this direction
mr. president thank you thank you for
talking with us
thank you and Seba